john where are you the truth came out
like a half hour ago sorry man i had a
pickleball hot dog
hurry up the trailer is one thing but
what everyone really cares about is our
reaction
you know this i know i ah crap
i spilled mustard on my suit all right i
need to finish setting up this is the
second he gets here we shoot the
reaction
hey warren what's up man cosmic wonder
here to tell you that the spider-man
trailer is finally out no i know i'm
just waiting for john's show up well
hurry up dude every leak that i've ever
reported on including conflicting
reports are all true and all in this
trailer what
how's that possible woof woof greg
woof woof
hello welcome to the heavy spoilers
phone call i'm your host paul yeah i i
know who you are paul i i know you are
did you see this spider-man no way home
trailer or like spider damn no way
holmes
no not not yet well you better hurry up
yeah i uploaded my trailer five minutes
ago you sucker
already how'd you get it done so fast
hello it's eric voss from new rockstars
oh no way
eric what's up how did i have my number
who's better at hunting for numeric
clues than myself
okay i was just calling to let you know
that
even if our reaction video goes up later
than yours
we'll still get more views
why are you guys getting into reactions
out to don't you already have the most
viewed breakdowns and now will be the
most watched reaction channel too
[Laughter]
and i don't even need to put my face in
the thumbnail
i've tried it's too fat it doesn't fit
hello hey greg it's chris from 3c films
sorry man i'm a little busy right now
how the heck are you going to do a
cringy intro for spiderman without the
master of cringy intros in your videos
congratulations bye
stop
what what's up man
you all right
i'm i'm sorry tyrone i'm just
so stressed right now man
even though we're like competing
reactors it
really means a lot that you're always
looking out for me and always wanted to
lend a helping hand
thank you
why did something come out
you mean you don't you don't know
no whoa what came out
that nothing just there's nothing i
don't know it gives me up there's
nothing yet
[Music]
aaron's here all right the spider-man
trailer's finally here let's do this
some suggest that parker's power is
included
to hypnotize females
[Laughter]
devil in disguise
this is like immediately after that
but this isn't about me this is hurting
a lot of people this feels so dark i've
just been thinking about how to fix all
of this
look just like stranger so peter
me
yeah
that feels weird but i'll allow it
i've got screwed up
mercy
never
right
don't cast that spell
he's too
is about to dangerous that peter parker
spiderman wait everyone
not mj yes some people still know that's
not how the spell works
oh my god
oh [ __ ] oh my god wow
[Music]
hello peter it's really happening
oh boy oh yes december 17th doesn't say
coming soon we got that release date
baby number 17. oh my goodness that was
awesome that was awesome i really really
love it seems like it's gonna pick up
immediately after the events of that
awesome post-credits scene and far from
home where he's like trying to escape
and that one guy in the really looks so
much like he didn't see his face but the
way the outfit was like i think that's
charlie cox he's doing the legal defense
for him yeah right there man we freaking
we saw him
that was like that lived up so much
that lived up so much yeah absolutely um
yeah i mean you gotta see the green
goblin ball right there oh my god
and then uh doc ock hello peter oh man
that was so overwhelming and uh the
stakes feel so real the consequences
feel so palpable like it was so dark in
the first half of this trailer
and you know it's got this like
harrowing sad effect of like that really
is it's like the extreme version of what
we know about peter parker a guy who is
just trying to have a good life and be
spider-man but usually it's deal
suffering with the secret of being
spider-man now it's how do i deal with
the public thinking i'm spider-man
knowing i'm spider-man but also thinking
i'm a murderer you know how do i go back
to school like he's trying to right
there you know but before i just start
saying too much i need to catch my
breath uh john you go next time now this
look absolutely incredibly exciting to
me and i mean i love just how much even
though we have expressed concern about
the mentor figures and how much they
take over the movie i would be lying if
i said i wasn't completely on board for
all of the mind and and reality bending
chaos that it looks like this movie is
going to bring with dr strange in it and
like to see him and peter bouncing off
of each other and yeah like the aspects
of this that do delve into peter's life
and yeah that core theme of your problem
is you're trying to balance both man you
see what happens when yeah everyone is
led into peter parker and that looks
really intense just as much as all the
crazy sci-fi stuff does so i'm really
excited for this aaron you're up my
friend i could not do this without you
you introduced me to spectacular
spider-man please take it away oh my god
there's so many cool things in this
trailer from dr strange
altering time playing the fiscal role of
the what was it no one day war story and
i thought that was very interesting kind
of twist and it feels like this movie is
divided into two halves with the first
half really addressing the consequences
like an immediate pickup after far from
home and the second half is this
multiverse adventure of madness i'm just
like blown away like to to steal your
term nipple chills yeah that's amazing
yeah holy [ __ ] and this is like like all
the rumors and speculation we've been
seeing for months and just like all of
these it's all the smarter versions
live-action spider-man literally despite
it yeah
the the visual confirmation of seeing
doc ock in the mcu blows my mind and i'm
so hyped for this movie i've been
waiting so long to see the return of the
characters i love from my childhood
brought to this new franchise and i'm
just i'm so overwhelmed with excitement
i'm literally shaking there was one part
there with like electricity that kind of
looked like it could have been electro
appearing in the black suit yes and
there was another time where i'm not
exactly sure but i kind of might have
thought that was lizard in the
background i don't know we're trying to
do that one thing where we won't take it
we just gave you guys a sketch
question so i'm calling for a memory way
over there
i will say that like dr strange there
was something a bit off about his
behavior though there was something
there
that seemed
devilish seems a little more reckless
after everything they've been through
he's like let me just do this so i got
this it like seems like really it's like
yes he's he is stern generally speaking
but uh the the amount of risk taking i
don't know what do you guys think do you
think he was a little bit there's
something a little mischievous about his
performance i felt a bit like i don't
want to say sentence yeah that's the
word yeah yeah it seemed out of
character for him because knowing
everything we know literally the first
dr strange movie dealing with time and
the whole reverse third act and then him
not him seeing being so opposed to
giving thanos the time stone and
infinity war it seems odd he's like yeah
yeah we'll just change your life yeah
this doesn't have any effect on anything
and then him like going behind wong's
back with the little wink and yeah it
felt very
off like very something i'm i'm willing
to put like
a hundred dollars that there's not
actually there's there's a twist there
coming that you can kind of tell yeah
it's gotta be missiles let's bring that
back in the detail what picket sign
as i really feel like one thing that can
sometimes miss for me in um far from
home and homecoming is like a the
consequences feel much more palpable b
his style like you actually got a sense
of true cinematic style in this trailer
with like specific framing like it looks
and shot different than the other two
that he's done and you know i feel like
there's something about like bringing
back some sam raimi characters in here
we all know toby and andrew and this are
right like
they're in this so um yeah like with uh
bringing back some of these returning
characters from like the raimi films
especially i can imagine he's like i
better i better like live up
i mean this one is now fully fledged
into the mcu as well and it feels like
that
appropriately with that bump in
production what value and imagination
and the last thing too i had a concern
that this would not feel
like um you know a peter parker movie
like like this would feel like uh by a
bunch of other things which you get a
lot of that in this trailer but it still
feels like no this is tom holland's
peter parker he is this is his story his
specific journey that we're going on
everything around him just going to be
supporting
i like i love that i was still so
invested in what peter's journey is here
and like having to deal with the
mistakes he's making too you know like
it seems like this is a big
you know mess up of just a bunch of
people's choices yeah
i loved it i loved it um i i really
loved it and yeah yeah okay all right i
gotta be real with you i'm i'm like over
the moon hyped about it that i i don't
even have a bit of my critical mind on
right now okay i know maybe you're
really good you're just feeding it yeah
okay i'm fed into it i've been waiting
for this trailer for like a year and a
half we all have
this yes all the way guys subscribe
click that bell aaron thank you for
being here smash that like button that's
that thumbs up button also big thank you
to everyone who appeared in that opening
video for us uh that actually took us
more time than you might think to put
that video together and uh yeah we had
eric voss 3c films cosmic wonder heavy
spoilers tyrone magnus watch all their
videos they're definitely covering this
as well thank you guys catch you guys
soon